.
GREAT JOB DOWN THERE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Jesse: WE TOLD YOU YESTERDAY
THAT GOVERNORS IN TEXAS AND
FLORIDA ARE BIDEN SOME OF HIS
OWN MEDICINE.
GREG ABBOTT, TEXAS, BUSING AND
FLYING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN HIS
STATE STRAIGHT TO WASHINGTON
D.C.
AND RON DESANTIS IS DUMPING THEM
IN BIDEN'S HOME STATE OF
DELAWARE.
PRESS SECRETARY JEN PSAKI WAS
ASKED ABOUT THE DROPOFFS TODAY.
WATCH.
>> WHEN THEY GET -- ARE YOU GUYS
GOING TO HELP THEM FIND A PLACE
TO STAY AND SOMETHING FOR THEM
TO DO?
>> I'M NOT AWARE OF WHAT
AUTHORITY THE GOVERNOR WOULD BE
DOING THAT I THINK THAT'S PRETTY
CLEAR THAT'S A PUBLICITY STUNT.
HIS OWN OFFICE ADMITS THAT A
MIGRANT WOULD NEED TO
VOLUNTARILY BE TRANSPORTED.
THEY CAN'T COMPEL THEM TO
BECAUSE, AGAIN, ENFORCEMENT OF
OUR COUNTRY'S IMMIGRATION LAWS
LIES WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
NOT A STATE.
>> FLY TO WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
THE I KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR OF
TEXAS OR ANY STATE DOES NOT HAVE
THE LEGAL AUTHORITY TO COMPEL
ANYONE TO GET ON A BUS.
>> Jesse: MY NEXT GUEST KNOWS
ALL ABOUT BEING A PRESS
SECRETARY AND POSSIBLY A FUTURE
GOVERNOR.
SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS JOINS ME
NOW WITH HER TAKE.
ALL RIGHT SARAH HUCKABEE
SANDERS, IT'S GOOD TO HAVE YOU
BACK HERE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, TOO.
>> Jesse: IT IS KIND OF SAD
THOUGH THAT THESE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ARE BEING USED AS
POLITICAL PAWNS JUST TO
EMBARRASS JOE BIDEN INTO
ACTUALLY DOING HIS JOB DO YOU
AGREE?
>> WELL, JOE BIDEN HAS DONE A
PRETTY GOOD JOB EMBARRASSING
HIMSELF.
HE SENT A MESSAGE VERY CLEARLY
ON AT A ONE OF HIS
ADMINISTRATION THAT THE BORDER
WAS OPEN TO THE WORLD.
HE HAS NEVER ONCE TAKEN ACTION
TO SECURE OUR BORDER OR TO STOP
PEOPLE FROM COMING IN.
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP, WE HAD A
SECURE BORDER.
WE WERE WORKING WHETHER IT WAS
THROUGH THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY, THINGS LIKE TITLE 42 OR
THE PHYSICAL WALL ITSELF.
OUR BORDER WAS FAR MORE SECURE.
SINCE BIDEN HAS COME IN, HE HAS
ALLOWED A NATIONAL SECURITY, A
HEALTH AND HUMANITARIAN CRISIS
TO TAKE PLACE AT THE BORDER,
ALLOWING THE DRUGS AND CARTEL
VIOLENCE TO FLOOD IN ACROSS OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER, AND I'M
THANKFUL THAT GOVERNORS ARE
STEPPING UP.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT IT IS GOING
TO TAKE.
BECAUSE WE CANNOT COUNT ON THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT UNDER BIDEN'S
LEADERSHIP TO ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING.
THEY HAVE CREATED THIS PROBLEM.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO ONLY CONTINUE TO ALLOW
IT TO GET WORSE.
AND SO I'M GLAD THAT STRONG
CONSERVATIVE GOVERNORS ARE
STEPPING UP AND TAKING ACTUAL
STEPS TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
BECAUSE WE KNOW IT'S NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN AT THE HANDS OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
>> Jesse: THAT IS FOR SURE.
I KNOW PEOPLE IN YOUR STATE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT CORRUPTION.
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT CORRUPTION
HERE.
AND THERE'S A LOT OF CORRUPTION
IN WASHINGTON AS YOU OBSERVED
WHILE YOU WERE THERE WORKING
VERY HARD.
SO, AOC ACTUALLY CALLED OUT
NANCY PELOSI TODAY BECAUSE, YOU
KNOW NANCY MAKES A MINT TRADING
STOCKS -- EXCUSE ME, HER HUSBAND
DOES AND SHE BASICALLY SAID THIS
IS REALLY CORRUPT WHETHER IT IS
OR IT JUST LOOKS LIKE IT.
LISTEN.
>> THERE IS A VERY, VERY DIRECT
CONNECTION BETWEEN US HOLDING
OURSELVES TO A HIGHER STANDARD,
HOLDING AND HAVING THAT INCLUDE
OUR FAMILIES AND, YOU KNOW,
THERE ARE MANY DIFFERENT
PROPOSALS HERE, BUT, YOU KNOW,
WHETHER IT'S SPOUSES, WHETHER
IT'S CHILDREN.
WHETHER IT'S SENIOR STAFF
MEMBERS WHO ARE ALSO IN THE ROOM
WHEN IT COMES TO -- WHEN IT
COMES TO WRITING DOWN THE ACTUAL
TO BE AGE TO ASSURE THAT IT'S
NOT HAPPENING HERE AND THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT IF
THEY ARE COMPETING WITH THEIR
MEMBER OF CONGRESS' STOCK
PORTFOLIO IN ORDER TO BE HEARD.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS A DIRECT SHOT
AT THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
YOUR REACTION?
>> LOOK YOU, I'M ALWAYS PRETTY
SUSPECT OF ANYTHING COMING FROM
AOC, BUT ONE THING THAT I MIGHT
SAY I SLIGHTLY AGREE IS THAT
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS SHOULD NEVER
BE ENRICHING THEMSELVES WHEN
THEY ARE THERE TO SERVE THE
PUBLIC.
AND SO I CERTAINLY HOPE THAT WE
CAN HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I WOULD COUNT
ON HER TO BE THE PERSON TO LEAD
THAT CHARGE.
>> Jesse: Y.
I WOULDN'T PUT HER IN CHARGE OF
ANYTHING BUT AT LEAST SHE SAID
THE RIGHT THING THERE.
>> AGREED.